Rogers with us in Miami hey Roger
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thank
you good afternoon how are you better
than I deserve what's up hi so I'm a 24
year old I'm at about one hundred and
fifty four thousand this year alone that
and I just want to know if I should
worry about paying if I want as soon as
as soon as possible I used some of this
time to sort of build up their savings
and buyers buy a condo or something
where I get a mortgage that's cheaper
than my current rent and then focus on
paying alone off Wow
my current rents about $1,500 a month
Wow yeah what do you do for a living
half well I'm a pharmacist well that's
good news
yeah so you making 111,000 when you get
out here
when'd you get out couple months ago
good for you well I'm proud for your
income I'm scared to death for you on
these student loans here's the thing
six months ago you were living like a
broke college student right now you make
a hundred eleven thousand why don't we
keep our lifestyle down and pay the
student loan off in a heartbeat like two
years yeah like have no life you
remember when you used to have no life
remember before you got rich
you just got rich right you just you
just hit the lotto 111 thousand bucks
and you you were you were you know you
know you were eating ramen noodles
before remember okay yeah so go back to
the ramen noodles for two years and be a
hundred percent debt-free
okay okay I could just tell by that
you're ain't doing it so let's keep
working on this um the the other thing
is as a pharmacist have you investigated
yet how much money you can make on the
weekend working at the hospital no I
haven't I've been doing some overtime
though oh good yeah I've been doing
overtime and using that money to saving
how much does everything 40 hours money
come talk about cost two thousand eleven
thousand dollars over my paycheck come
on
we a month it could be $2,000 right the
overtime so 2,000 a week my mom 24,000
okay so here's what I'm looking at your
154 and I'm looking at this 154 as you
have this wonderful story of your life
that you've just told me until you told
me this 154 and it's almost like I've
got this healthy young guy who's got
cancer
and I'm saying cut the cancer out fast
don't play with it like it's a pet
that's what I'm telling you the shortest
distance between where you are with your
fabulous income and your great choice of
career by the way congratulations well
done the shortest distance between you
and being where you are today and being
a millionaire is to clear that student
loan debt like it was cancer I agree the
rent I feel like I'm paying too much in
there you are $1,500 a month so I either
wanted to find a cheaper place to rent
or save a little bit get a mortgage on
you know home and then my mortgage
payment you know hopefully have that
reduced to something like 800 or 700
doesn't call the payments and I end up
owning that condo whatever I buy you
know that that's right that's really
intellectual but not wise okay you know
you've worked that through with your
brain but out here in the real world
that's gonna bring a bunch of crap into
your life right now today I'm talking to
a a excellent employed broke 24 year old
you're a hundred and fifty four thousand
dollar negative net worth you don't need
to be buying a house so ya rent the
cheapest thing you can are taking a
roommate you do need to make a move on
that but listen this is a hundred
percent focus on the on the debt we're
going to clear the debt we're gonna
clear the debt we're gonna clear the
debt and then I do want you to go buy
something Miami is a wonderful market to
buy real estate in it's a great real
estate markets great town it's got a lot
of flavor a lot of spice there it's
wonderful I love the town but yeah but
but yeah you have the ability to make a
lot of money make a lot of extra money
now your doubt yourself down to nothing
no life like you used to do when you
were studying to be a pharmacist you had
a singular focus a singular goal you
were delaying pleasure to win
you're paying a price to be a stud now
you're the stud now pay one more price
and clean up the stinking mess you made
with those debts cuz dude man if I'm
talking to you at 26 years old and
you're 100% debt-free and you have the
ability make $150,000 a year and you're
gonna so much money you're gonna be just
paved the Rope man which paved the
interstate and set a Ferrari on it
you're gonna you're gonna be in good
shape but right now I set a Ferrari on
it and all I see speed bumps so let's
get let's get the thing smooth out here
then that's what I would do
hold on I'm gonna send you a copy of the
book the Total Money Makeover that
outlines exactly how five million people
are doing what I'm trying to talk you
into doing so I'll help you I'll show
you what to do I'm honored to have you
in my audience and great career choice
Roger well done well done man that's
awesome
open phones this hour as we talked to
your talk to you about your life and
your money man when I first started the
show 25 years ago there were zero smart
24 year olds calling me zero now I get
to talk to them almost every day the
twenty five twenty six twenty eight year
olds that I'm talking to you right now
are some of the smartest I've ever
talked to in a quarter of a century that
I've done this you people to think these
Millennials are stupid they're not
stupid some of them are lazy but most of
them are awesome this is the Dave Ramsey
show